c'est le président monsieur le ministre
comme mes collègues précédent l'ont
souligné
le vent est à nouveau en feu l'offensive
massive que la turquie vient de conduire
dans le nord-est de la syrie
anéantie d'un seul coup tous les efforts
que la coalition avait mené coalition
dont la france est le deuxième
contributeur et tout cela risque bien
évidemment d'être ainsi très positif
pour des ch qui n'en est qu'ils n'en
attendait pas tant
le bilan est accablant déjà près de
mille morts à l'heure où nous parlons
160 mille civils réfugiés lancer sur les
routes
le retour de dèche et le risque peut
être pire encore d'évasion de
djihadistes qui vont venir faire payer
très cher
l'europe pour son engagement enfin les
kurdes les cures de nos alliés les
kurdes nos amis qui se sont battus avec
temps d'héroïsme pour notre propre
sécurité
ce peuple sans patrie ce peuple trahi
une fois de plus qui est contraint
d'appeler au secours ses ennemis d'hier
les américains ont cru défendre leurs
intérêts mais quelle confiance accorder
demain à leur parole alors
monsieur le ministre mes questions sont
simples
tout d'abord comment le temps peut-elle
rester sans réagir
nous étions un certain nombre dimanche à
l'assemblée parlementaire de l'otan et à
nos questions forte nous avons fait
entendre la voix de la france
le secrétaire général stoltenberg n'a
jamais daigné répondre
et par ailleurs que comptez-vous faire
face aux millions de aux milliers
d'usagers dalle de djihadistes qui
menacent notre sécurité
le ministre annonce son départ pour
l'irak qui espère-t-il obtenir là bas et
surtout pour les français pour notre
nation
que comptez-vous faire ici en france
pour assurer la sécurité des français
pour vous répondre